all of a sudden the article clothing you
love is missing and you'll never see it
again ever and you don't know where it
went that happened to me like in my life
like with like a like a couple dozen
things like i have a shirt i wore it all
the time i'll see it one time in a photo
i'll go
i've never given that shirt away i don't
know where that shirt is that shirt is
gone gone gone did that never happen to
you no
i have lost clothing i i'm thinking of
one shirt in particular right now right
but i've lost clothing and do you know
that i spend time in my life thinking
about where it may be and the life it
has now and i've i've spent time in my
life being like
where could i have lost it and what was
the journey like like like it's final
like in an american tale like it just
went on a journey after me the shirt and
somebody found it at somebody's house
and maybe they donated or somebody just
said i'm taking this and they wore it
and what what where that shirt went in
his travels and what it saw after it
left my body is that weird i like
daydream about the shirt on somebody
else
in a riverboat somewhere and like what
does this thing seem after me whose life
is it a part of now